Donald Trump firing Rex Tillerson as
Secretary of State has set off a chain
of events i already partially described
to you the deputy CIA director gina
Haspel presumably potentially I think
I'm saying presumably becoming being
elevated to CIA director miss torture as
she is known really really horrible the
other horror is that CIA director Mike
Pompeo is Donald Trump's choice to
become Secretary of State and he has the
notable honor or shame depending on how
you see it of being the top all-time
recipient of coke industry money ever
okay Mike Pompeo was a Republican
congressman from Kansas right up in
Kansas for six years and during that
time opensecrets.org which tracks
campaign contributions has determined
that Pompeo was the top recipient of
money from Koch Industries and the Koch
family and coke funded PACs of all time
in the 4 election cycles that you see on
screen that he participated in 2010 2012
2014 and 2016 Pompeyo received 335
thousand dollars from Koch Industries
employees including a hundred thousand
alone from the Koch family sixty nine
thousand dollars from the Koch
Industries PAC and over four hundred
thousand dollars from Americans for
Prosperity which is the Koch brother
founded right-wing PAC and then another
nearly ninety thousand dollars from
other groups heavily funded by the Koch
brothers more than nine hundred thousand
dollars for one congressman and now he
is in all likelihood going to be the
secretary of state of the United States
this is very very good for the Koch
brothers if you're the Koch brothers you
say what a great investment we made our
guy the guy we bought is going to be the
top diplomat for the United States
around the world and Pompeyo is a
straight-up climate denier he when he
was being confirmed actually for CIA
director he didn't really answer any of
the
questions that were posed to him about
his climate change beliefs basically
saying listen I'm gonna be CIA director
I'd rather not get into that as if
that's sort of more political and okay
you can maybe sort of try to make that
case as CIA director but if you're going
to be Secretary of State
issues of climate are major major issues
the Secretary of State is involved in
worldwide climate negotiations in
international aid and development that
is impacted by the climate you are as
Secretary of State a major player in
decisions about energy sources right so
first of all a climate denying Secretary
of State working in the United States
for the United States and 2018 is just
disgusting and vile but secondly I hope
and honestly I'm so disillusioned that I
doubt it's going to happen I hope that
senators will hold Pompeo accountable on
these issues during his confirmation
hearings because during the CIA director
confirmation hearings it was pathetic
they just let it slide and at the time
again he said well I'm gonna be CIA
director I don't wanna get involved in
that I just have no optimism that this
is going to happen and once again the
United States under Trump becomes even
more of a laughingstock around the world
and in the background
it's the Koch brothers right it's very
very easy and we've talked about this
with everything that's going on to just
forget about the influence of people
like the Koch brothers but their
influence is everywhere right it's not
just politicians they fund as an example
the young America Foundation they
sponsor speakers around the country
including at colleges including Ben
Shapiro and Ann Coulter and Karl Rove
and Newt Gingrich and Rick Santorum they
fund Turning Point USA it's another one
of these dark money PACs which funds
right-wingers like charlie kirk also
trying to infiltrate campus politics and
we recently just did an interview which
we talked about in detail about how the
Koch brothers and Koch Industries they
pour money into academic institutions
they they fund professorships at
economic departments they fund research
at other academic departments at
colleges and universities and they are
influencing what students are
being taught at our institutions of
higher learning around the world around
the country and influencing American
policy around the world truly perverted
yeah I think it makes sense why they're
funding academics in research right but
why would they choose Mike Pompeo as
their top guy I mean he was only a
congressman for six years you'd expect
maybe 20 30 years then they'd start
funding him a little bit more and he's
also from Kansas too which is a safe
Republican district yeah I think it's
more about not I don't think it's so
much about helping him win races that he
might lose to a Democrat I think it's
really more about just having a guy in
their pocket yeah a guy on their side
that's kind of how this works they see
it as an investment and the time horizon
for the investment doesn't have to be
super short right it can be for some
future point and they they hit the big
time right CIA director not as useful to
the Koch Industries Secretary of State
super useful to Koch Industries at this
point so it's depressing right I mean
what what could I possibly come up with
something to tell you that would make
you not worry about this I don't think
so I'd have to lie to you and I don't
want to do that so this is bad this
shake-up that is happening and and
listen I was the first person to
criticize Rex Tillerson and his Russia
friendship and his commitment to fossil
fuels but it it ended up being that he
was one of the on a spectrum more
rational voices within the Trump
administration and it's a very
irrational administration big picture
and now he's gone and the shake-up that
he is causing is just not good it's very
very bad you also say the same thing
about Pompeo ironically too because Gina
Haskell who's poised to replace them
yeah it's arguably worse arguably worse
than Pompeo so it's a shift that's not I
I can't think of any way in this way in
which this will be good here's the mate
the possible silver lining may be the
new deputy CIA director replacing Gina
Haspel will be better than Haspel that
would be something that we can maybe
hope for and be disillusioned with next
week once we find out how bad that
person's gonna be or something my job to
provide the silver right yeah yeah I'm
digging very very deep here send me your
thoughts about what's going on and about
this shake-up I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the shows on twitter at david pakman
show and we've got it's really a good
one today I'm glad that today's Pro
gram is working out well for everybody
involved today's program is sponsored in
part by blinken
we all lead busy lives sometimes it can
sort of become a struggle to do all the
reading that we want to do I know this
is certainly true for me
there are probably a bunch of books that
you've been hoping to sit down with and
read but you've not yet been able to
find the time what if I told you that
you could read a full-size book in 15
minutes or even more quickly
that's basically what blinka s'tel aoz
you to do blankest is a mobile app that
takes thousands of the most popular and
critically acclaimed nonfiction books
and summarizes them into their most
important points and they present it to
you in the form of text or audio so that
you can either read it or listen to it
in 15 minutes you get all the same
information and insight from the book in
a fraction of the time you can search by
author or topic new books are being
added all the time it's an almost
endless diverse collection to choose
from politics science health and fitness
psychology parenting business you're not
going to run out I think is the point
I'm trying to make of fascinating
informative nonfiction reading and
listening material and bling cast is
free to try and membership after that is
only a few bucks a month and you can get
a 20% discount off of that if you go to
blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube we've put a link in
the description underneath the video
that is blink accom /pa que ma n